I really enjoyed this movie a lot Sambi
Monster Mash it was kind of right up my
alley so as always the target audience
but something I loved was opening aerial
sequence and you got to shoot such a
cool moment in that can you talk a
little bit about getting that shot of
you coming down from the plane oh man it
was definitely my favorite sequence as
well but it was so difficult just
because what I'm afraid of heights
I'm not afraid of heights but you know
just kind of I don't like it no but they
had me suspended
I wanna see maybe like 50 or 60 feet in
the little rig that they had and it was
just like a gyrating machine basically
that would just spin me around a bunch
different ways and they just had a
camera connected to and just spin me
until I got dizzy and just couldn't take
it anymore but I mean it was a lot of
fun like the entire sequence took about
it we can have to shoot and there's so
many moving parts but everybody was
committed to it all the guys that were
on the plane with us we're all committed
to making a great scene and I'm really
proud of it I'm really proud of the
final product for sure how it looks
great thank you so I know that the
soldiers went through like this sort of
boot camp but you get to do your fair
share of ass-kicking as well what was
your training like so I I train on my
own a sport wise I went to the gym quite
a lot because I in 1940 she didn't have
a lot of money to eat so I wanted to be
more fit for the part and also when the
guys came back after the boot camp we
start working with each other I was
holding weapons and that was very
interesting because I've been watching a
lot of film were lead actors hold
weapons in a very contemporary way and
in 1940 woman was holding hands not I
don't like I was expecting it so that
was very interesting it was the first
time as well I was touching real weapons
so at the beginning I was a bit scared
and then I loved it they had to take it
away from me
she's like got a flamethrower in your
bag
yeah oh it looks like you guys got to
work with some really great practical
effects too how is it dealing with the
more monstrous element on set and having
something real to work with I think you
see more so than me especially with the
the mistake yeah you spent a lot of time
with him wasn't was incredible because
basically what you saw in a film was
what I what I have in front of me so it
was kind of rediscovery and the crew was
this extremely talented and they did
such an amazing job so it was a quite
easy actually to to be afraid I just
have to react basically and yeah it was
really amazing experience I was hip in
for you guys dealing with the bad robot
level of secrecy and now you're you're
almost out of it you can talk about it
now
it's good you know I think even early on
like as soon as the filming was finished
you know we started getting like tweets
and you know dims and Instagram about
like is this a part of the Cloverfield
here are some things like that and we
just didn't know because that never was
a conversation that we had we were
filming we had this story but these
characters in these circumstances and we
just remained committed and that like
there was never a thing of like you know
play this because it could be involved
in this world later so it was kind of a
bit frustrating because we couldn't
answer any questions cause I didn't know
but it feels good that now people are
seeing what the project is and have
really come to appreciate it so it's a
great time did you guys get any crazy
theories lobbed at you we did but
there's so many I could even like
remember like a specific one like is
this like a foreshadowing of you know
this character from the last colorful
movie and I'm like uh I don't think so
but you know but maybe you know you
don't want to you don't ruin anybody's
expectation yeah he's just afraid of
spoiling basically most of the time and
and how I can talk about the film
do you make people want to watch the
film anus
kids mister straightly so you're like
come I say things right I remember
reading that some of the actors on the
last Cloverfield film didn't even know
they were making one until later it was
like you thought and I said a very well
bin that's exactly you know it was
refreshing to know that you know we were
definitely gonna live in our own
universe and you know gets a because you
know if you're a part of not two not
that it's bad to be a part of any other
universe but it's more freeing that you
can kind of just live in your world with
your characters and not have to you know
follow an outline so I thought it was
pretty awesome that were anything yeah I
was like I'm glad it's not I'm glad it's
its own world
right twisted low universe how was it
like working with the kid cuz he's so
great it was absolutely incredible
he's a he's such a crude actor yeah he's
really good actor he had a lot of energy
but he's really good it was perfect for
the part and before shooting the family
I had spent some time with him we went
to Harry Potter world and then then
together and we pretend we lied actually
that it was his birthday because when
the kid is this birthday they can push
the big door and we said I said to the
guy he's his birthday it was like he
just pushed out the door when he was at
this amazing so no he was oh he's such a
he said she's just little man ever and I
really hope he was here today in two
because he can be proud of his work he's
a little scene stealer Yeah right so
it's not true what they say about
working with kids do want not true what
they say about working with kids it
seems like this film has a really
concise ending that feels contained but
obviously box office has demands of its
own would you want to return to these
characters in this world first seek or
do you hope that the film gets to live
on its
I think that there's always a space for
for the characters in the horn I think
it could I think it could go either way
and be just fine it could be a good
thing you know for both routes I think
the way that the story ended you still
might wonder what happens after Chloe
you know what happens next in her life
like does she stay in France does she go
somewhere else like and that's what most
of the characters so I think there's a
world that it could go either way and I
think everybody's open to whatever may
come in the future yeah I'm always down
to see people messing up more Nazis
Hudson well I got to wrap with you guys
but it was a pleasure it just means I
found the film thank you so much